今天要聊一個很有意思的案例。一家巴西公司 Builderall 找來一位新 CEO，任務很明確，就是要他去「攻佔」美國市場。結果這位 CEO 接了任務，卻反手就把這個任務「拒絕」了。
拒絕了？這還真是出乎意料。一般公司高層，特別是新上任的，不是都想著開疆闢土，往外擴張嗎？怎麼會有人把這麼大的市場機會往外推？
對啊，這就是最有趣的地方。他不是隨口說說，他是深入研究了公司的數據，發現真正的機會，其實藏在他們原有的客戶資料裡。
數據？現有客戶？怎麼說呢？聽起來有點像老生常談，數據分析大家都在做，但很少看到有人能從中發現什麼「出乎意料」的藍海。
其實，這就是他的創新點。他看 Builderall 的美國客戶數據，表面上這些人都在美國，看起來的確像美國市場的初步成功。但當他深挖這些客戶是「誰」的時候，發現他們幾乎都有西班牙裔姓氏，而且都集中在佛羅里達南部、德州和南加州。
等等，這裡我有疑問。有西班牙裔姓氏、集中在特定區域，這能說明什麼？不還是美國客戶嗎？
原文提到，這些人並不是「美國人發現了拉美產品」，而是「從拉丁美洲移居到美國，但仍然與原有的拉美生態系保持連結」的族群。
哦，我懂了。所以他發現，這些所謂的「美國客戶」，其實是他們在拉丁美洲市場行銷的「下游效應」，是拉美市場的自然延伸。這就改變了整個策略方向。
完全正確。他沒有盲目去砸錢開拓美國市場，而是選擇回頭，更深入地經營拉丁美洲。這樣一來，原本在美國出現的客戶，會變成一種「附帶結果」，自然而然地增長。
這點我是信了，因為原文有提到具體數字。拉丁美洲的金融普惠率，從 2019 年的 45% 沒銀行帳戶，到 2023 年降到 21%。網路普及率更是從 2012 年的 43% 跳到 2022 年的 78%。這些宏觀數據，說明了這個市場本身的巨大變化。
對，這些宏觀趨勢讓拉美市場從「老市場」變成「新市場」。很多競爭對手還在用舊思維，舊策略去打，反而給了 Builderall 這樣能快速應變的公司一個窗口。
這種做法對創業者或主管來說，的確是一個很好的啟發。在資源有限的情況下，不必總是盯著那些「大家都在搶」的市場。也許把手上的客戶資料重新盤點一下，就能發現新的機會。
沒錯。尤其對我們台灣的中小企業主，或是服務業、傳統產業來說，這真的非常適用。與其想著怎麼去海外開分店，不如先問問你的老顧客：「你最近還有什麼不方便的地方？」「你最希望我們提供什麼服務？」搞不好，新的成長動能就藏在這裡面。
但這種模式撐得久嗎？如果大家看完這個案例都去挖數據，這不就變成新的紅海了嗎？
其實這個案例還提到一個重點，就是「拒絕與最強的對手競爭」。如果 Builderall 硬要打美國市場，就必須直接跟 Wix 或 Squarespace 這種巨頭對決。在拉美市場，可能就有不同的競爭態勢。
也就是說，除了看見機會，還要懂得「挑軟柿子吃」。不跟實力最強的對手正面衝突。
是的。那對於一般上班族呢？這個概念能不能帶到我們日常的工作中？
我覺得，上班族也可以從這裡學到一件事：很多時候我們被主管要求去「開創新業務」「開發新客戶」，但或許我們可以先看看自己手上的「現有專案」或「現有客戶」，是不是還有什麼沒被挖掘的潛力？
有道理。比如說，你負責的某個部門，或手頭上處理的一些文件，有沒有可能從中看出一些「規律」，然後去改善流程，或發現新的需求？這就有點像在公司內部找自己的「拉丁美洲」市場。
沒錯，其實就是不要只看表面，多問幾個「為什麼」。為什麼這些客戶會選擇我們？他們真正的需求是什麼？這種深度思考，好像也提醒了我們，有時候答案就在眼前。